oh hi you know buying games on wii where
it's a lot different than buying games
on the competition's download services
wiiware games don't have demos so you
can't try them before you buy them know
so it's a high holy pain in the ass to
have to delete a bunch of stuff from
your wii so you'll have space for the
new game so before you part with your
hard-earned bling what we want you to do
is take a look at these videos of some
upcoming games for wii we're two that
are out in the u.s. right now and a
couple that are coming up very soon i
don't want to say that homestar runner
is so 2003 but I'll admit that I no
longer regularly keep up with this web
cartoon series but that doesn't keep the
wiiware game strong bad's cool game for
attractive people from being fun and
funny what's available on wiiware now is
the first of five episodes each of which
is going to pack a few hours of
point-and-click adventure game play if
you remember how to play leisure suit
larry clicking on things and solving
puzzles you know how to play this the
puzzles are difficult but not impossible
in strong bad's quests to humiliate his
athletic rival home sorry you'll have to
engage in lots of dialogue with the
whole cast of the cartoon who've been
recreated quite nicely in 3d you'll
collect ridiculous items like hedge
clippings or a metal detector and you'll
have to use them to accomplish crazy
goals like stealing home stars criminal
record out of a castle using a plunger
at ten dollars it's a little on the
pricey side but the sheer amount of
content is well worth it a little less
worth your ten dollars is helix now I've
always thought it might be a good idea
to have a musical wii game where you
score points by waving the controller in
a variety of different motions to the
rhythm of the song but after spending
some time with this one maybe not helix
is kind of like playing dance dance
revolution with your hands you choose a
eurobeat song that you've never heard of
from a list and then you wave punch
uppercut and mashed potato while holding
two wiimotes you can play the game with
just one but you'll lose all the points
you get for using your other hand
the problem with helix is that it only
recognized some of my hand movements
when I was playing it there's there's a
serious learning curve and that's not
good for a music game like this that
really should be fun immediately Oh at
all kind of felt more like a concept
demo and not like a full game that I
want to pay money for here's a wiiware
game that's not yet available in the US
if you remember alien crush and devils
crush those awesome science fiction
themed pinball games for the turbo
graphics they're both available on the
wii's virtual console they've been so
popular the series is making a comeback
on wiiware alien crush returns is a full
3d reimagining of the classic pinball
game which was inspired visually by
movies like aliens the pinball board as
you can see is uh I don't know what the
hell it is actually the guts of a space
creature an alien homeworld both who
cares it's fun aliens are crawling all
over the board you can hit them for
bonus points there's a story mode that
gives you a series of small challenges
and boss battles so you're not just
playing the same table over and over for
a high score and power-ups add a little
bit of strategy into the mix so you can
give your ball a speed boost or reverse
its direction I'm having a lot of fun
with this and if you enjoy video game
pinball so will you battalion crush
isn't the only retro game getting
resurrected on wiiware in the near
future the grandfather of Japanese
arcade games space invaders is
celebrating its 30th anniversary this
year and taito is releasing space
invaders get even true to its name it
turns the tables on the classic story
for the first time you'll get to play as
the space invaders as they invade Earth
controlling the UFO mothership and
surrounded by your armada of pixelated
invaders you'll fly over cities and lay
waste to buildings armies tanks
helicopters everything now it's not just
a mindless shooting game there's a timer
ticking down getting hit lowers the
timer and shooting buildings etc raises
it so you've got to always manage that
space invaders get even is a lot of fun
but it's also kind of secretly expensive
it only costs five dollars to download
the game but that only gets you about 30
minutes of game
it's like three levels if you want more
levels you have to pay five dollars for
each of three new level packs so the
whole thing ends up costing about 20
bucks I'm not sure when space invaders
is going to be released in the US but
when it is you should definitely check
it out
you